je sais que tu as fait tes d'études dans
une institution religieuse fait mal
parce que c'est à bourg-la-reine et que
l'autre live mail attente la cotation at
il dit il a vu avant il aurait dit
bourla maintenant un état plus elle peut
plus fait je suis là calme et tu là je
sèche voilà ils sèchent doucement dr
myers a confessé telle habitude qu'ont
fait ces commentaires alors tu me suis
bien avec moi dans l'hôtellerie
c'est vrai que tu procèdes des actions
charitables dans les hôpitaux
oui je le dis pas trop au centre parce
que ça c'est parce c'est pas à crier sur
les toits c'est ma vie à moi et je le
fais tu fais vraiment oui c'est vrai que
tu est la marraine d'un petit garçon
indiens font pas beaucoup d'anglais
banon n'a pas forcément besoin de crier
sur les toits tout ce qu'on pense qu'on
peut faire maintenant si tu veux c'est
une chose que je fais parce que j'ai
envie de le faire et puis c'est tout et
j'avoue ne pas savoir ne pas en prendre
bonjour cher est un parce que tu grandis
oui tu prison break
le jour où ça se traduit comment vois-tu
prise une rue prieur ou une brûlure à
toi aussi ma vie mes prières dans toutes
les questions que pose est ce soir que
les seuls qui te le plus embêté c'est
que tu vas me poser maintenant alors
j'ai posé la question comment ça se fait
maintenant vraiment pour la dernière
fois
comment ça se fait que tu n'es pas je ne
serais pas marié tu n'es pas d'enfant
que tu sois tout seul sait comment c'est
possible sans quelque chose qui arrive
et je suis pas forcément tout ça c'est
un tout seul que ça tue avec quelqu'un
comme cela
et crêtes
c'est ça qui est en baisse quand on
parle de ça et vous
ça va me dire moi quand même sans
forcément on en tire ou vous trichez n'y
a que vous qui posez ces questions des
enfants ne cause pas croire que toutes
les saveurs sont bouygues tout
compliquer très cher